друзі всім добрий вечір відриваючи
дванадцятий день війни я якраз
почалася в українець означає годину вам з
норми платформою масивного Петра in
яка офіційним проектом міністерство
світи україни святі наук україни і я і
мудро трубними страшками сьогодні у нас
доволі на звучній є c є з кіпру
виньї
лікером сім'ї кандидатом на дачних наук
і
практикам навіть black and a
проектом у видачі нам наступне з андрей
головешки головешки і я з вашої дози
була постити ефір на російську
моя там у нас є це ж добра розмірі
українську алея думаєш що з введенням 3d
Андрій добрий вечір вам добрий вечір ну
як у вас на кіпрі все спокійно і
сподіваюся
так тут теж беремо участь у актах допомагаємо
сюди прибуває ось так я чув у нас
досить велике ком'юніті українців на
кіпрі і зайти сфери і не тільки через
ці сфери тому там можна бути багато
наших за ідеєю ну власне у нас
сьогодні тема трохи не про волонтерство
це більше про психологію тому
що
кожен напевно мешканець України
зіткнувся з проявами війни в тій
чи іншого ступеня хтось безпосередньо
під обстрілами та у підвалах хтось для
когось це більше по телевізору та
витає у повітрі але так чи інакше вона не
обходить стороною нікого і тому всі ми
чули таке слово як
посттравматичний синдром багато хто має
напевно дивилися фільм чи читали
літературу на цю тему розкажіть у
професійної точки зору що це
взагалі таке до кого він має відношення
тут хоче трошки зробити невелике
відступ
у мене теж і в Україні вийшла теж у
останнім часом теж дві книги одна з
моїх книг наведена українською мовою
людини листи ось і друга книга
воля до життя якраз якщо не помиляюсь
був тираж харкові і я отримую від
читачів те, що ця книга вони з собою
беруть навіть спускаючись підвал
тому що вона їм допомагає якщо назва
воля до життя здавалася надто химерною
ще буквально рік два тому зараз воно
якраз є найдоречнішим
суть у тому, що мені хочеться поговорити
мені хочеш сказати що ми часто
вважаємо що стрес та травматичні
події які з нами відбуваються це і
це завжди травма це завжди погано
є нам завжди так навіяли що завжди
стрес нас ламає завжди у нас робить
гірше і
переконання це сама по собі вона небезпечна
для здоров'я було дослідження в якому
показали що люди які вірили що
стрес шкодить здоров'ю вони показували
найгірші показники
фізіологічні та найгірші показники
здоров'я ті ж люди, кому провели лекцію
пояснили, що стрес є і можна
використовувати його та корисним для тіла що
наші тіла створені боротися власне
кажучи
люди і меч переконаний переконання що стрес
можна конвертувати на користь для себе
витягти з нього силу як джерело
енергії ці люди вони краще протистояли
стресу та й на об'єктивному
фізіологічному рівні за результатами
аналізів його набагато краще приносили
тому головна думка яким не хочеться
завести стрес це просто енергія вона
може бути і руйнівною і
творчої все питання як ви
здатні трансформувати це як
ядерна енергія вона може бути бомбою
може виробляти тепло ось так енергія
стресу не треба вважати що вона
спочатку по собі несе лише зло
несе лише тут негатив
ось і коли ми говоримо про травму тут
є завжди два виходи і завжди два
виходу перше це посттравматичне
розлад вихід про які
формується ось другий варіант це
посттравматичний ріст та
дослідження показують, що ті люди
які мали певні
інструментами та змогли пропрацювати
що сталися з ними вони показували навіть
покращення показників свого здоров'я
така тут хочеться уточнити момент
пов'язаний з травмою та ви сказали про
травму травма мається на увазі
психологічна травма, що сталася
внаслідок стресу або в результаті
як це все формується
ну ми можемо уявити собі таку
психологічну травму та як фізичний
стрес але і в цілому на принципі
меншості людей для більшості людей
це більшою мірою
такий психологічний землетрус
назвемо її так коли наше уявлення
про те як має бути влаштований світ, що він
в принципі більш раціональної
таке це уявлення не як би
руйнуються і
тут завжди у нас така травма коли
особливо походить річ від якої від нас
не залежить у нас завжди є ризик
наприклад формування вивченої
безпорадності ось це випробування
безпорадність це мабуть сама
жорстка яка потрібно пройти щоб не
отримати вивчену безпорадність тобто
не здатність діяти в цих
ситуаціях ми можемо фрустровані ми
можемо зневіритися у цінностях
людської підтримки ми можемо нашу
агресію просто проектувати на інших
людей і це неправильної реакції при
спробах впоратися з травмою саме
перше до самого першого важливий момент
знову таки який виходить з
експериментів ще 60-х років це
проактивність тобто робити що завгодно
навколо себе формувати зону автономного
поведінки ось у всіх експериментах
показано що травми та стрес змушує
вас як триматися і зрештою нам
хочеться лежати просто нічком і нічого не
робити і навіть не приймати те що
відбувається а нам потрібно протистояти
цьому бажанню тиснути
навпаки розширюючи зону автономного
контролю так я можу робити це я можу
допомогти цим людям я можу зробити ось цю
річ тобто що саме зараз
знаходиться в зоні мук мого контролю та
чим більше ми можемо взяти під контроль
тим впевненіше і краще почувається наша
психіка ми протистоїмо ми як би
протиборством цьому стискаючим посилити
дія стресу ось я думаю якраз
цю тезу можуть підтвердити багато наших
співгромадяни тому що я пам'ятаю навіть там
свої реакції реакції багатьох своїх друзів
колега знайомі до так далі першого дня
це просто повний шок нерозуміння що
взагалі робити, а потім виникає якесь
бажання до чогось зайнятися починаючи від
того щоб прибрати квартиру закінчуючи
якимись волонтерськими історіями світі
хоча б там
якоюсь роботою вона може бути навіть не
супер корисно на той момент але щось
треба зробити для того, щоб не
перебувати у стані цього як
виглядайте безпорадності до переходу
активності про відповідність до цього
це дуже важливий момент тому що
люди як я нічого не можуть зробити це
вкрай шкідлива думка і по суті вся
пропаганда спрямована на цю думку
щоб змусити себе відчути свою
нікчемність ти ніхто ти нічого не можеш
робити змирись терпи і насправді
важливо розуміти щось деструктивне
думки і важливо їм протистояти тобто
наша людяність по суті полягає
ось у цій свободі волі що робити
універсальної поради немає тому що
кожна людина унікальна вона знаходиться в
своїм кунда унікальному місці тому
питання що робити озирніться навколо себе
вийдіть озирніться на вулицю
запитайте
перефразовуючи відому фразу
американського президента не питай
що світ може дати тобі запитати, що ти
можеш дати світові треба такий підхід буде
правильніше добре і відповідно це
можна назвати першим таким наріжним
каменем як можна зменшити хоча б
згодом так чи там рівень цієї
травми яка може бути нанесена але
будь-якому випадку ми почали з вами говорити про
посттравматичному
зростає як про одну з опції до авто
другий варіант це посттравматичне
як ви сказали правильно 2 літри
розлади давайте розберемося напевно
з цими двома категоріями що є
перше що з ладу напевно з
розлади краще почати
ну розлади 3 рази таки погіршення
якихось наших адаптивних здібностей
ось насправді хочеться більше
поговорити про зростання тому що
розладом сформується як це без
лікарської допомоги і все мені собою та й
швидше це хочеться просто щоб це то
що не відбувалося ось тому більше
хочеться звернути увагу на те
щоб зростання чому цей важливий момент і
чому це вікно можливостей
вона так обмежена ось напевно якщо
дивитися різні старі фільми на
примірку ти новачок приходить монастир
його піддаються складним випробуванням
таким петрограда даний вид стати його
піддавати сильному стресу і тільки
потім коли він вже зневірився приходить
коли майстер каже ну ось тепер ти
можеш сприйняти істину це насправді
справі такий давній біологічний прийом
справа в тому, що кортизол і високий
рівень стресу він знижує кількість
зв'язків між нейронами та по суті наших та
це старі уявлення наші якісь
ідеї вони слабшають є у нас виникає
таке вікно можливостей та
потім коли стрес зникає ось питання
що зміниться у нашій особистості це
питання які цінності сенс і narrative
ми покладемо ось у це ось що звільнилося
простір варіантів вікно можливість
у нашому мозку тобто мовчки вибачте
поправте якщо не виходить що ми
маємо можливість під впливом цього
стресу та кортизолу як наслідок
перепрошуватися так можна так сказати
все вірно і тому критично важливо і
це відбувається скрізь я теж це бачу
створювати нові історії narrative
сенс і тобто те, що буде створено ось
в цей ось унікальний момент та ось у
цю про france можливості вона як мозку
нас конденсується і потім ймовірно
визначатиме вже подальшої
траєкторії нашого мислення наших
цінностей мозок плавиться як сказати в
загалом ми такі люди консервативні і ми з
працею міняємось але наш мозок плавить
наприклад або дуже сильний стрес або
дуже сильне задоволення
ось якийсь ну в даному випадку
зміни відбуваються на жаль таким
чином
добре і як ми тоді можемо взяти під
контроль напевно ось ці зміни та
перепрошуватися краще набік
сенс полягає в тому, щоб
діяти проактивно знову таки вони
реактивно на основі своїх цінностей
це дуже важливо тому що новий сенс
створює те, що ми не жертва
обставин поняття а ми захисники
своїх цінностей насамперед і ніхто
ніщо не може зробити мене жертвою без
моєї згоди тому що в будь-якій
ситуації я можу бути прихильним до свого
цінностям і це дуже важливо, бо
людина яка діє на основі
своїх цінностей це зовсім інша
особистість ніж людина яка
підлаштовується під обставини це
принципово різні позиції я ось частина
рекомендую питання що читати та
рекомендую читати ось така філософія
важких часів це стійки це епітета
це марк аврелій роздуми люди
які жили в непрості часи та як
раз таки сенс стоїцизму був полягав
в тому щоб як би так ось хокінг
нашої поведінки діяти не на прапорі
біологічних тригерів там страх гроші
влада
саме поставити в основу нашу поведінку
мотивуєш речі це саме базові
цінності ось і людиною вранці вони
вважали не ту людину хто йде по
обставинам того, хто діє по
цінностям
тобто перекладаючи на близьку нам мову
не ми жертви агресії, а ми боремося там
за за свою свободу, наприклад, не я
змушений там волонтерити чи не знаю я
втратив роботу а я там допомагали, наприклад
комусь там армії друзям бабусям ще
комусь там біженців ключа та й тут
є одне з цікавих відгалужень
українка об'єктивно поведінковою
психотерапії 100 багато гілок багато
поколінь воум але одне з них мені
здається але підходить для зараз
найкраще ця терапія прийняття
відповідальності вона мені називається
англійський стт сенс полягає в
найважливіших моментів, які допомагають
впоратися з тим, що відбувається перше
це прийняття тобто це не осуд
це не спроби пояснення це саме
прийняття того, що відбувається прийняття
чистого дискомфорту так що це означає
ми не намагаємося це пояснити та створити
такого брудний дискомфорт шлейф тобто
що зі мною не так раз зі мною це
трапилося ми говоримо ну є такий
реальність іншої реальності нема ось
тому ми приймаємо цю реальність
замість того, як страус ховатися
від неї тому що чим швидше ми приймемо
те, що відбувається без осуду
емоційного шлейфу і без якогось
розправитися тим паче адекватно ми
діятимемо
багато людей які намагаються якось
закрити очі відсторонитися
дисоціювати від реальності такого немає
не зовсім адекватно психологічний
механізм він у багатьох людей є все це
це цього не відбувається це зону як
люди кажуть насправді вони втрачають
дві важливі речі а не втрачав здатність
реалістично діяти тому що вони
спираються на це уявний
реальність б вони нічого не можуть
навчитися
тому що прийнятті реальності вона
формує для нас можливість вчитися не
тільки на позитивному досвіді, але і на
негативним тобто умовно кажучи цегла
які кидають нас ми вбудовуємо свою
фортеця стіну яка захищає от і
тому ти сидиш ми тобі говоримо про кей
неважливо хороший відбуваються або погане я
відкритий новий досвід я буду вчитися я
приймаю те, що зі мною відбувається
друга частина цих правил терапії
прийняття та відповідальності полягає
якраз у дотриманні цінностей
тому що ми беремо на себе
відповідальність за не просто реагувати
як тварини біологічні та там
страшно біжу тихо сиджу ось а саме
діяти на основі своїх людських
цінностей це по суті і є те, що
робить нас людьми
супер андрей знаєте що в цьому контексті
хотілося б дізнатися вашу думку якій
з приводу ось зараз ми бачимо те, що багато хто
українці покинули свої будинки та
[музика]
відчуває з цього приводу якесь почуття
провини щось залишився наприклад а ось я
поїхав або навпаки там батьки
бабусі-дідусі наприклад залишилися не
виїхали і я винний або винна що я
їх там не вивіз не вивезла
як це можна пояснити і що потрібно
робити у разі якщо в людини
виникають такі питання до себе
мені здається, що краще бути відповідальним
чим бути винним
тобто просто для себе позиції
вини воно знову таки має на увазі що ми
якось
зробили щось і насправді у нас був
вибір зробити щось інакше насправді
ну як з погляду сучасної
біології ось у моменті прямо тут і
зараз ми практично на свободу вибору
нема так ми можемо аналізувати свої
дії
якось по-іншому тут планувати
намагатися змінити минуле випробовувати
вину за минулим це непродуктивно
тому що минуле вже неможливе
змінити це просто факт
тому це просто як це сказати це
просто спроба витрачати свою психічну
енергію без того, щоб зайнятися чимось
важливим точно так само як не спроба не
приймати реальність боротися з тим що
відбувається це просто конфлікту
висмоктуючий сили не дає нічого
натомість тобто теж потрібно поставити
якийсь ментальний 100 км але таких
роздумах та й все-таки жити
працювати з тим що є скажемо так то
є ситуація, яка вже виявилися
добре давайте повернемося тоді
посттравматичному зростанні багато разів ви
сказали про те, що потрібно діяти
відповідно до своїх цінностей
як правильно сформулювати ось
я знаю у корпоративному секторі достаток
можна сказати що недра часто компанії
там формує свої цінності та деякі
роблять це від балди пишуть просто
якісь гарні слова для того, щоб
була деяка проходять достатньо
велика кількість велика кількість
ітерацій для того, щоб усвідомити зрозуміти
і сформулювати це все чому я
наводжу корпоративний приклад мені здається
що не кожна людина в принципі
усвідомлює ну свідомо підходить до питання
про те, що є його цінності, внутрішня
або може бути я не правий і люди апріорі
якимось чином розуміти, що для них
важливо як ось у цій історії зрозуміти що
важливо для тебе усвідомити це прийняти і
діяти через призму цих самих
цінності
[музика]
мабуть
скажемо так ну скажемо так одна з
цінностей якщо брати страшно філософію
стоїків, про які ми говорили це
наприклад сміливість сміливість та мужність
ось наприклад цілком
не корпоративна цілком особиста цінність
на противагу боягузтві
це ще у стародавніх стійків одна з
чотирьох базових цінностей античної
філософії, які тут ходила це
здатність приймати реальність
здатність рішучість та здатність
знаходити нові можливості для того
щоб перетворити травму зростання давайте ось
цю цінність тоді з вами трошки і
розкриємо не кожен може взяти зброю в
руки і піти боротися в силу
об'єктивних причин не знаю що сьогодні у
нас запис в територіальній обороні в
армію значно перевершує
можливості прийняття людей у ​​принципі
в ряди в технічну плюс є жінки
діти і так далі, тобто в чому може
виявлятися
сміливість крім
варіанти ну всім зрозумілого брати зброї
там йти захищати свою країну але
це можна виразити старі фрази
досить відомою яка стосується це
наприклад, може бути виражена фраза
дослідження просто своєму
боргу
тому що мене чути
жаль технічні проблеми з
інтернетом зараз у наших умовах це
не новина у нас сталося те саме
тому ми продовжуємо
говорити з андреєм говориш кіно на ту
ж тему, яка стосується
посттравматичного зростання і до того як
нас відключила з ефіру ми обговорювали
питання цінностей питання стояло у цінності
яка називається сміливість андрей якщо
можна з цього моменту
може виявлятися до життя людей
теж підійти такий трішки філософського
підходу
психологічного по суті
сміливість полягає це не тільки
умовно кажучи військова сміливість святого
більшості людей слід сміливість і
розслідування свого обов'язку
ось тобто те, що називали так ось
латинське слово коли проти virtus
який мужність слідувати тому що ти
повинен ось це друга фраза яка
прийшла прийшла ще й теж з часів
античних це
робиш що маєш і будь що буде так
але якщо ще склеїти її двома іншими
вийде така при match 4 частини фраза
думаючи найкращим готовий все гіршому роби що
повинен і будь що буде і по суті будь
що буде це і є прийняття будь-якого
ряду сценарій роби що повинен це ну
ось тобто по суті це слідує своєму
боргу те, що ти повинен робити з нами
цінність сміх твоєї ситуації ось це є
сміливість тому що сміливість це не мене
ні не завжди героїзм сміливість
продовжувати робити ті речі, які ти
вважаєш за потрібне ось і вся в принципі
сміливість
супер тобто за великим рахунком якщо ти
не зраджуєш сам собі
узагальним цю історію то це вже можна
сказати як прояв цієї сміливої
цієї сміливості цієї цінності для тебе
коли це безумовно
надана підвищується з стійкість тому
що дослідження психологів які
пройшли концтабори Другої світової війни
вони показали що найбільше виживання
мати ті люди, які мають ну як це
сказати таку більш розвинену сама
ідентифікацію почуття почуття
самоповаги
власну цінність тобто кадрові
військові
релігійні діячі
ось тобто дворянство тобто такі
люди які немає рази майже тему
самоповаги не набагато краще проходять
будь-які важкі випробування по суті будь-який
будь-який стрес він спочатку приводить до того
що людина втрачає себе
втративши себе людина як би опускається
до гарантує набагато швидка швидкість
і
суті досвіду ось цих усіх психологів
які пройшли і концтабори та вижили
просто роками полягає в тому, що
насамперед ні за яких
обставинах не треба втрачати себе
тому що це найцінніше втратив себе
все інше вже по суті просто
приведе до повільної деградації ось і
суму бути собою супер тобто по суті
ніяк я буду пристосовуватися до
ситуації а як я діятиму в цій
ситуації ось це питання ми повинні
собі задати і в цьому і є це зростання
правильно коли ось у нас часто кажуть
про те, що війна знімає маску з людей і
на побутовому рівні та на політичному
рівні на будь-яких рівнях більше чоловіків
зрозуміло хто є хто можна віднести
ось цю ситуацію до того про що вмовив
я думаю так тому що більшість ну
частина людей могли просто
ну так поводяться багато психопатів days
at захід і вони просто
прихильники певної соціальної
норми і дуже вміло маскуються
під цей аргумент але в разі чого ця
вся морська може миттєво злетіти
з багатьма людьми просто на жаль так
вона буває тут і відбувається з іншого
сторони деякі люди просто схильні
психічним епідеміям та
це може їх просто як ментальний вірус
прямому сенсі вражати це здається
смішним але наука описує реальні
психічні епідемії, тобто навіть часів
середньовічної Європи, де люди хотіли
білик друга палицями по спині та танцювали
тобто це було буквально заразне
певні стратегії поведінки
так що психологічна гігієна теж
важливо якщо ти у тебе розвинені
інструменти ви приймаючи то ти по суті
маєш такий імунітет і пропаганду та
імунітет до різного роду стресу
одяг добити я один одного палицями ми не
дійдемо дуже хочеться в це вірити
добре андрея тоді цілком практичний
питання ось сьогодні багато наших
співгромадяни
буквально ночують у підвалах підвалах
бомбосховища народжуються діти там проходить
життя там тисяч і тисяч людей та
дуже часто ми стикаємося із запитами
в рамках нашої платформи що ось я з
дітьми вже там мама наприклад пиши так
я з дітьми там уже тиждень сиджу кудись
обстрілами в підвалах там я дах рве
просто я розумію що я винна там якось
дітей заспокоювати я сама не можу не себе
заспокоїти нічого плюс ось це все
оточення навколо мене теж на нервах
стресі і ось як такій ситуації стоїть
діяти людям про що думати про що не
думати дайте рекомендації будь ласка
напевно, сама базова річ це створити
порядок замість хаосу, бо
руйнування звичних норм створює хаос і
у тіні нашого життя всі наші звички
якісь злітають а нових не утворюється
наш мозок він дуже любить структуру він
дуже любить порядок хоча б заспокоює
коли є це передбачувано історія
тому перше, що потрібно зробити це
просто взяти аркуш паперу та скласти
розклад
будь-який може бути це робимо 20 хвилин
потім 21 робимо це і чітко слідувати
ставлю пункти закреслюючи і
можна зовсім з нуля для себе створити
розклад на день уперед і це буде
реально
заспокоювати, включаючи якісь речі
включають і базову рутину їжі та
фізичної активності перемикання і так
далі коли мало рухів і важливо
розуміти що навіть якщо ми замкнені
приміщенні все одно важливо рухатися
тому що будь-який рух вона
перешкоджає стресу і ми по суті як би
спалюємо
надлишку великого за надлишку жирної
кислоти стрес викидати нас крім
того
будь-яка двигун на активність вона
допомагає виробляти гальмами та
медіатори які нас заспокоюють
є якщо є якесь сильне
психічне збудження ви потрібно зняти
фізичною втомою просто присідаючи
або віджимаючись і фізична втома
вона просто дасть найкращий сон
тобто по суті я ми знову повертаємось
до того ж, з чого починали я створюю зону
в які я можу приймати рішення
якою я можу діяти проактивно
правильно і правильно і так само я створюю
собі як би можна сказати ілюзію
або якийсь кокон у якому я приймаю
рішення в якому я дію проактивно
тобто умовно я міг не можна ми ж не
вигадуємо те, що ми робимо це
реальні справи
не фантазії з приводу того, що я зараз
вийду нічого не і все буде як раніше
тобто це це таки не ілюзія
це реальні дії у реальному світі
це важливий момент а
що робити з
часто непереборним як здається бажанням
кудись втекти навіть якщо це
небезпечно просто сьогодні ми
стикаємося з ситуаціями коли люди
фізично біжать від обстрілів та потрапляють
під ці обстріли замість того, щоб
наприклад перебувати в бомбосховищі або
підвалі
важливо розумієш в умовах стресу як
ми часто дуже часто дійством
автоматично тобто у нас по суті
5 f5 зашитий реакція базовий у нас є
лайт тікати fight битися фриз завмерти
saint
втратити свідомість до прикинутися мертвим
і по суті feedjit тобто трястись
просто на місці
тривоги, але нічого не робить і ці
всі реакції вони генетично
запрограмовані та коли ми діємо
імпульсивно ми не можемо адекватно
відреагувати просто залежність від
нашого темпераменту вибираємо ту чи
інший спосіб дії та
один із важливих моментів
посттравматичного зростання це пошуковий
поведінка та креативність
тобто як мінімум для себе придумати
кілька альтернативних варіантів
тому що при стресі у нас відбувається
така називається тунелізація мислення
тунель зводиться і є тільки чорне та
біле та
це тому, що часто дією
абсолютно неадекватно ситуації тому
що ну бігти або падати мертвим це
могло нам допомогло врятувати життя там сто
тисяч років тому, але кожна ситуація
зараз найчастіше унікальне тому
первинні ось цей імпульс він не завжди
призводить до розумних рішень гри то
є я з огляду на каналізація мислення це
коли я враховую там лише один фактор
наприклад і при прийнятті рішення немов
стріляють не стріляє але не дивлюся на
ситуацію з різних боків, що не дає мені
можливість ухвалити адекватне рішення
що відбуваються правильно
цікаво
так вибачте ні так все правильно сказати то
є виходить виходячи з цього ми можемо
порекомендувати людям не приймати
вирішення тієї ви такому жорсткому стресовому
стан коли людина розуміє що у
нього панічна атака краще нічого не
робити заспокоїтися почекати, поки це
пройде у відносно безпечному місці
потім вже зважувати з різних боків і
приймати більш раціональне
рішення таку ми можемо дати рекламу
але це складно сказати тому що в
реальності
небезпечної ситуації якраз випадків
це потрібно діяти негайно
замість того щоб взагалі дихати або
робити це залежить від конкретної
ситуації але якщо немає безпосередньої
загрози життю якраз таки краще
привести себе у стан здорового глузду
щоб приймати адекватні рішення
і
і і я не можу вибрати бігти бити або
заміряти умовно та тобто це
відбувається автоматично правильно я
розумію у людини у кризовій ситуації
так це імпульсивна
здійснюємо так реакція як і бажання
лаятися зовсім недавно писала пост
якого просто щоб допомогти людям не
звинувачувати себе за це що насправді
такі як інструменти як чорний гумор
або вчених називаю такими одним словом
імпульсний набір слів це навчальна
посвята лаяти і вчені вони нас на
насправді у дослідженнях вони підвищують
больовий поріг
ось і допомагають протистояти впливу
стресів ось тому будь-яким
копінг-стратегій мда впоратися ви
вдається якщо не для вас працюють то
не треба себе за це звинувачувати тест сваритися
у цій ситуації це цілком окей
я думаю так просто робота для лікарів я
ось як колишній нас козелок реаніматолог
такий цинічний медичний гумор, який
не зрозумілий обивателям він насправді
не тому що лікарі так і злі погані
тому що вони теж стикаються зі
смертю і це допомагає їм просто це
таким чином переносити
так я пам'ятаю у мене просто двоюрідний брат
хірург вона працює німецької в одну з
клінік і я пам'ятаю його анекдота з дитинства
про те, як там лікарі до землі кого
привчали або там ще подібного роду мене
це здавалося дикістю звичайно по
зовнішньому та я потім зрозумів навіщо це йому
і чому в них гумор весь і знову на ось
таких ось якихось незрозумілих для
звичайних людей речах тому мені здається
ми теж щось подібне переживаємо
сьогодні і тут є ще одна реакція
яку хотілося б з вами обговорити це
ось воно з'явилося буквально недавно там
день два тому напевно масово серед
тих з ким спілкуємося та тих запитів
які у нас є це знаєте як якась
спроба раціоналізація тобто пошуку
чогось хорошого в тому, що трапилося
коли до стріляє зате і починається ось
до паніки рефреймінг пошук
позитиву починають якихось супер
глобальної політичних всесвітніх речей
там нація і так далі закінчуючи
якимись простими речами там зате
поїхали не знаю зате помирилися з кимось
за те ще щось ну і до нескінченності
ось яка природа цієї реакції
це абсолютно нормальна реакція це
здорова психіка просто протистоїть
накопиченого негативу і
тобто по суті у нас є такі 2
нейронних мереж у мозку 1 шукає вам
хороша якість ніж погана і наприклад
людина у депресії він завжди помічає
як би гірше речах ось а здорова
психіка вона навпаки намагається шукати
хороші тому що добрий допомагає
підтримувати рівень та серотоніну та
дофаміну тому це нормально і
фокусуватися на будь-яких речах не
порушених травмою це дуже гарна і
виграшна стратегія навіть на абсолютно
простих речах навіть більше
люди
починають ще більше цінувати звичні
речі тому, що вони вже перестають
сприйматися як має їсти така та
а техніка ось у стійках негативна
медитація вони рекомендували
щоб гостріше сприймати
задоволення від речей сприймаєте як
незмінною річ це ж практика якщо
буддизм тобто ти уявляєш собі
ситуацію медитуєш що в тебе немає
того що ти володієш ніби ти
втратиш а потім ти відкриваєш очі та
бачиш на тобі тобто і ти виконуєш
ся задоволенням ось і багато людей вони
починають розуміти як тендітний цей світ у
котрі вони прямо зараз живуть що вони
можуть позбутися цього загубиться в
будь-яку секунду і тоді у них повертається
особливо і гострота та задоволення таких
речей це абсолютно нормально і цей
досвід він я повинен думати трансформуючий
сприяють зростанню тому що ми перед
ми перестаємо приймати ці речі як
повинні а вчимося їх цінувати та розуміти
справжню важливість себе або ця
історія про смачний соковитий стейк який
ти хочеш з'їсти після після дієти і він
здається набагато смачніше набагато соковитіше
ніж якщо ти їж його щодня
[музика]
майже ну а стейк це нагорода та перу
У будь-якому випадку з'їси, а тут це навіть не
поки що ти його з'їж ну та й від цього
це ще важливіше
добре андрей багато питань ми з вами
обговорили сьогодні я думаю їсти вже з чим
працювати для того, щоб витягти назвемо
це так користь для себе для своєї
особистості ситуації, що склалася і хотілося
б від вас таку наприкінці фінальну загальну
рекомендацію для всіх людей які
опинилися тут потрібне це повчання
позитивна якась знаєте таке зарядом
один одного я чимось добрий
найкращим двоє нам саду ніж із садівником на
війні як говорили ще давню і
мені здається що
будь-які наші зміни не відбувається тоді
коли ми стаємо воїнам не випадкового
шалінський монах та практикуючі
усвідомленості медитації це вони це
зробили на основі саме бойових мистецтв
і
це мені здається мусить навчити нас що
за наші цінності за всі важливі потреби
боротися вони не даються нам просто так і
цей досвід боротьби він може нас загартувати
як насправді кування стали робить її більш
міцна бічна з неї шлак так ця
ситуація може зробити нас більш
сильними як особистість усунувши та вибивши
з нас від цього якісь слабкості
сумніви і зробити населення тому мені
хочеться щоб ми сприймали стрес як
можливість та й навіть травм можливість
посттравматичного зростання приймали ту
реальність слідували своєму обов'язку щоб
це робило нас тільки сильнішим
супер велике дякую за за хороші
слова та і корисні рекомендації які
кожному з нас я думаю знадобляться у
сформованих ситуаціях
друзів що це був андрей головешки
психолог кандидат ми дачних наук та
рамках платформи масивну петренко
міністерство святі наука україни ми з
вами зустрину маси сніданок завтра 20 00
розум з психологом так тренером а ну і
про світла і також будемо говорити про
прищики може but i press не кожному з
нас до побачення до завтра та
букіною вам ночі